good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast
in studio beautiful faces being
shown everywhere it's so good to be back
we're so thrilled to be back in studio
post-quarantine
it's very exciting we were really
getting cooked up in our houses and it
is just
fabulous to be out with the people with
theo
with the fresh air corporate environment
here's the thing it's fabulous to be
here but you really touched on something
quite important it's fabulous to be here
with theo
i have not seen theo in two weeks and
honestly
like my heart was hurting it was aching
for him
we had such a beautiful ring in this
morning he's just like the most sweetest
most perfect man and i'm so blessed
honored and happy to be here
back working with him like it's such an
honor to work with you know your heroes
and people you really respect
and that's how i feel about working with
theo no i
i totally hear that i also think you
know at some point we were taking this
place for granted
i agree i mean what is weird is that
we've been gone for two weeks
and it really feels like two months oh
no and like the box is piled up outside
of our door like you think we're the
most
famous bloggers ever no like it really
felt it feels like first day back at
school but like it was summer break
it was just a two week queue no it was
just a two-week queue thank you guys for
keeping up with uh
oh my god i like forgot how to talk
thank you guys for keeping up
with us on the podcast we hope you
enjoyed those episodes but i'm not gonna
lie
i'm i'm pretty excited to be back on
camera looking fabulous those were some
good episodes though like the extremely
hasty flash
imagine if like you're someone who
doesn't watch
doesn't listen as a podcast like only
watches on youtube like you don't know
what happened
in the connecticut rest stop bathroom
and that's for you to find out
yeah that's for us to know and you to
find out yeah it was crazy
just be aware of those madison county
restroom bathrooms that's all i'll say
that's we'll leave it at that and you
know what if you rent a car get the
insurance
it's worth it um if you're into caring
at the insurance like there are some
things that probably even insurance
can't cover
yeah but some things that it does like
the towing which is very expensive did
it cover the towing
yeah we're figuring out what happened
we're still there yeah we're still
working out the logistics with the
rental car company but
c'est la vie you know it is what it is
it
is what it is and it's like once those
keys went down the toilet
there was nothing to be done no except
pay
the toll yeah and at the same time like
once those keys went down the toilet
like
it wasn't my problem anymore you know
like the rental car
that's probably actually the beauty of
having a rental car if it was my own car
it kind of would have been more annoying
like
you would have had below the toe you
might even have to like sleep at a local
hotel
in order to take it back in the morning
i just feel like you were done driving
for the day you were like i'm gonna
flush these keys down the toilet can i
just tell you how not subconscious it
was like
we were making such amazing time like we
had left on time
i was literally speeding we stopped in
madison for like
we'd done like almost 100 miles i was
like we're gonna get home so
early and i was really ready to just
like impress everyone with my driving
skills and my timing skills and my speed
skills and my logistics skills
and then you know as they say man plans
god laughs we were
detoured and completely devastated man
plans
theo laughs hi sweets i'm just glad theo
wasn't there to see his mom in this like
really low
point in his life yeah i'm really
i don't know i think he really would
have been disappointed in me i i feel
that
i do it's gonna be so hard for me to
focus today because like the sweetest
purest man alive is here and i just like
want to talk to him i want to catch up
with him like
we i told you guys in the podcast
episodes i've been facetiming you and
like i'd be like where's theo where's
theo and i just feel like we weren't
really connecting virtually because he's
more of an irl kind of it's hard
so i just like want to make up for lost
time no
he was talking to me you know keeping me
up actually really chatty last night oh
um just kind of saying how he felt you
know this distance between him and
everyone in the family
um but kind of specifically like pointed
you out um
just like you like really haven't been
there for him and he's kind of been
going through some stuff and he just
kind of he needed you
i know well if he picked up his phone
maybe we could have had a conversation
about it
but i love him so much no no i love him
so much
and that's what the show was missing so
that's the thing about the podcast
episodes they were good
but you don't get theo they were good
but they weren't great no
no they were not but you know it'll be
great hopefully fingers crossed today's
episode
fingers crossed one never knows but i
have a good feeling about it i'm feeling
energized
i definitely feel like when we take a
break oh it's
it all comes back full force and we're
like on
another level of excitement when we come
back was that not what you were gonna
say
no what i was gonna say was i feel like
when we don't do
video episodes or when we don't do any
episodes at all we like get back in the
studio for the first day
for like the first five minutes i
definitely feel weird like in the
beginning of this episode if you watch
me like my mouth is moving weird
i do i need like a two minute like
adjustment period so hopefully it
doesn't throw me off
because i really plan on delivering the
stories in such a fabulous way today
like i
went to bed last night and i was like
we're gonna be fabulous tomorrow
yeah and i think we're here and here we
are being fabulous question mark
question mark to be seen it should be an
exclamation mark but it's definitely
question mark but
it's just to be seen like the episodes
ahead of us and we don't know anything
could happen
no it's like it's like possibilities
it's like draft day the possibilities
for what's about to happen
are just completely endless and it's up
to us isn't that exciting it is it's us
and the team who took his spot center
stage
he's so symmetrical and like it's a
beautiful thing to behold
you just love to see it yeah you really
do um so i saw
a rumor yesterday that you started a
place to call home
um yeah i would say started like very
loosely i did pay for the seven day free
trial for acorn
and excuse me i watched two episodes of
the first season
it's um it's good it definitely has like
that hallmark vibe that i know you said
wears off it doesn't bother me
it's just like i'm i'm in such a weird
place in my life in such a different
place than i was
then i was in maybe a week ago i'm just
i have mad ben behind me now
and do you say mad ben yeah i've met men
behind me now and it's just like i don't
know if i'm in a place where i'm ready
to commit
full time to another seven seasons of a
show i'm still very much in like the mad
men hangover and i don't want to make
the mistake by moving too hastily i
understand that you need an
boosh you really do like an emily in
paris yeah she
is such a bush she's such an amusing
boosh
um i understand that two episodes into a
place to call home is like not where you
want to be because no but it's also it's
better than i expected even for everyone
said give it like four episodes
it's better than i expected even two
episodes said it's good okay but it gets
like better
it's like as if just the budget just
like blew up after
a few episodes and it's like the way
that they are on the ship like that ship
gave me such hallmark rides
well because the ship like grand dining
room was literally a rec center
yeah so that sort of thing stops and
like it becomes extremely high-end
and so i'm just excited for you i saw a
lot of toasters are on there a place to
call home journey and i just want to say
enjoy these days you guys because you
can't get them back everyone's on their
aptch turning no i know it's it's a
beautiful thing to behold
i i needed an amuse boost and it took me
like days to even get to the bouche
part so yesterday i read the new ellen
hildebrand book
trouble in paradise it's the third of a
series and i'm glad i finished it out
and the third one was probably the best
one but like the series just didn't do
it for me but it definitely
amused my bouche see different things
serve different purposes yeah and some
books aren't meant to change your life
like eliza starts a rumor
some of them are just meant to lose your
boosh until you're on to the next one
and i think that's totally fine
and i think the next one i'm trying to
just like prioritize all these things
that i have on my plate
and i think that the next one is gonna
be mariah carey's memoir
yes i started it you know what it's
really um
like difficult to get through it's so
dense
like i've really only been reading like
10 pages at a time but that's also just
me but i wonder if you'll have the same
experience i wonder how
it's heavy and the writer is really
going for it with these metaphors like
it doesn't i i would totally understand
and respect when people work with
writers for their memoirs
but at some point it needs to sound like
them and i actually have met mariah
carey and had dinner with her and i just
have to say this is not how she talks
okay like
i just can't really imagine it doesn't
the book isn't r it's in the first
person but it's not reading to me as
mariah's voice do you know what i mean
because the word it's so written not
like her but it's still very good
well i'm going to start it and i'll i
wonder if i'll have the same
critique yeah well i put it in your
brain so you didn't make it in my brain
which i hate
i get in my brain i know uh and aside
from that we're going to recap real
houses of potomac i feel like there was
one other thing that i watched yes there
was that i wanted to talk about
wild wild country have you heard of it
mm-hmm so it's a fascinating story like
really a crazy [ __ ] story
true story like really not to be
believed except for the fact that it's
true it's a documentary six parts
and the documentary happens to make it
extremely uninteresting and they're
dragging out
of this story like i've watched four
episodes and so many people told me to
watch it they're like you're gonna love
it this is [ __ ] nuts
and like i have to watch two more
episodes which i will but like
documentaries they really get so ahead
of themselves with like a six-parter
when it's like
give me a two-parter and you'll have me
uh hanging on your every word
yeah that's me right now in the vow i'm
on episode eight
and they still haven't made any arrests
it's such torture
and it's
it's just like honestly like i'm
starting to like resent the people
because like
just get on with it yeah it's and it's
like they had a meeting with the
attorney general
literally getting the meeting and
preparing for the meeting was a whole
episode an hour they didn't even have
the meeting in the episode yet like it
was the start of the next episode
that's even worse than what i'm
expecting it's insane like and honestly
i just want to see
like the sentencing i think that's the
most interesting and like when the cult
really starts to fall apart like who
doesn't want to see that
we haven't even gotten there yet and i'm
eight episodes in an hour each it's
crazy
yeah no that that's crazy there should
you would think at this point like they
would know but i guess
it benefits them to have more episodes
more ads like more time you spend
watching but like
at what cost yeah well it's like tiger
king and in my before tiger king became
like a cultural
like meme um i actually had some very
harsh critiques of the documentary
because while i thought it was good and
funny
it was way too long seven episodes about
a tiger like it's just so silly
um but apparently nobody else shared
with me because it became like the
biggest thing ever yeah or like if
there's a lull in the middle but the end
is popping off like you forget about the
lull because by the end you're just like
want to talk about it and
you can't believe this crazy story also
really quickly um i put up on my
instagram story like can anyone guess
what we're gonna be for halloween
and so many people were guessing carol
baskin and um
what's his name joe exotic yeah and i
just like i want to make you guys
uh make it abundantly clear like we
would never do that to you we would
never do that and it's unconventional
you know that i didn't even watch it
so i wouldn't know how to even do that
yeah it's also just like so unoriginal
like that's not who i am
you know and that's not who i want to be
no not at all that's not what i want
to like be displayed of my brand and
that's
i'm never gonna be
you can take me out of the country
it feels so good to be back singing
together i know on beat
and i still have like a little sticky
shoes in me
i feel my sticky sticky shoes
[Music]
honestly never doesn't like fail it
never fails to like
wait yeah no wait it never fails
to make me feel sexy oh is that the
right verbiage
yes that's right verbiage english is
hard we know yeah
um so yeah that's pretty much where i'm
at
if you were interested well cool cool um
did you want to
dive in i'm not sure
see like are you ready i only will
if you want to well i brought it up so
yeah so you want to that's you said
you're taking responsibility for this
dive yeah so i'll take responsibility
happily okay so without further ado
claudia says that it's time so it's time
she's at it for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and it's like i feel like i don't even
need to say this like today's ad almost
goes without saying
you know what i mean yeah like today's
episode
obviously is brought to you by bruce oh
obviously look at us
but you get that like just so it's so
obvious
it's so obvious you know um think about
how many times you brush your teeth in
your lifetime
you probably do it without thinking at
this point so if you're looking for a
dentist quality clean at home
don't brush your teeth brush them bruce
is the electric toothbrush we've been
talking about for weeks jackie and i
both have one we both got one in the
millennial pink it's kind of like the
same color as my sweater
it is such a game changer it's so sleek
looking it's so chic looking with the
little outlet in the little pad and it's
like magnetic
it's everything of the sort it comes in
a few different colors but the pink is
super cute
um and then like you know scientifically
brushing your teeth electronically is so
much better for you because the brush
um brush delivers premier sonic wave
technology and it doesn't have the
markups of big electric toothbrushes
so some electric toothbrushes are super
super expensive um but this bruce one
looks really expensive but it's very
reasonably priced
many electric toothbrushes are barely a
step up for manuals some do a good job
but they cost 200
and up bruce is just letting you have
everything that you need
for a reasonable price and for that we
have no choice but to stand and be
incredibly grateful
um and also i have this thing called
like rdh which some of the side effects
is bad breath so i like actually
have to brush my teeth more often that
than other people and with a premier
toothbrush and the doctor said it's
bruce or nothing at all
yeah that's what doctor for champions
like you better get a toothbrush um so
if you are looking
to elevate your teeth your breath your
brushing experience
get a brush stop wasting your time dilly
dallying around with these
toothbrushes that just aren't cutting it
and if you want to get 15 off your brush
use promo code toast at bruce.com that's
bruush.com
you can try it 90 days risk free and get
a two year warranty
at bruce.com b-r-u-u-s-h
dot com promo code toast check it out
and just
thank us later that's really all we have
to say yeah um it's doctor for chairman
approved
so you know it's the best in the biz
yeah four out of five doctor for
chairman's recommend
yeah and the fifth one has bad [ __ ]
breath sign on
thank us later sign on get your mask
breath a little better
oh yeah okay first story kylie jenner
and travis scott are sparking romance
rumors
after she shares steamy photoshoot pics
yes i'm not gonna lie this did throw me
off quite a bit
yeah for me it tracks but everyone is
like
you know are they or aren't they because
they're sparking reconciliation rumors
after they cozied up
for a sexy photo shoot they shared
pictures via instagram
on saturday of kylie and travis scott
posing next to a wall
jenner rocked a givenchy outfit which
included the sheer dress
crop round jacket and yellow heels the
highest in the room rapper who wore a
beige t-shirt and black leather pants
lifted his shirt to show off his abs in
one photo
what do you think um i haven't like been
able to keep up
with the kardashians literally on this
story it's like i never know if they're
together or not together and i feel like
that's how they want it like they don't
even know if they're together
um and obviously for stormy's sake like
i ship and i want them together but i
also want kylie to be in like the best
possible
most healthy relationship i don't know
if this is it but if it is like so here
for it
yeah i also feel like they spend so much
time together and i feel like on
kylie's stories like it's clear when
she's with travis even if they're not
posting like
steamy photos together so i just feel
like their family
period and this picture like doesn't
didn't even like alert me if they're
together or not i feel like they're
always
spending time together yes and she got
this like whole givenchy outfit because
that was like part of a
collab you know what i think um like the
new
design collection yeah first collection
and he sent out looks to everyone
important people and they posted them
yeah this photo doesn't really mean
anything they've
just been in the house together trying
on clothes because that's like what
famous rich people do
to me it meant ad for siobhan che yeah
completely
um yeah and everyone like really being
like cozying up with travis scott it's
like literally they have an arm around
each other that's how you take a picture
e news like have you ever like taken a
picture with anyone you just like put
your arm around them it's like really
not
people need to like relax a little bit
but it was just interesting that they
were together
yeah and i think it's you know everyone
like wishful thinking of course
i just feel like they know what's best
for them
yeah and i'm just trusting and believing
in them to do what's
best for their family yeah and i don't
really feel like i can you know sit here
and speculate because i don't know
what's best for their family
no but we just all saw the photo so
we're talking about a photo we're just
we're just speculating we're just
speculating you know i just said we
wouldn't which is art
yeah no we're just hoping we shouldn't
probably did you see kylie uploaded a
new youtube video to her channel
christina does my makeup
yes um so it i watched it on my tv last
night and then i went down like a little
bit of a rabbit hole with kylie's um
youtube videos and i really wish she
would have do them more often like i
know it's not like
the most important thing but i feel like
she has the time and like it would just
really make my life great she has 10
million youtube subscribers like why not
it would be great promotion for kylie
cosmetics and just good ad revenue
but the video last night was super funny
and it really reminded me of
her um app and she used to make those
videos all the time like ariel does my
makeup
like jordan does my makeup it was just
like her in her glam room like with
people doing her makeup
me doing my makeup and it was such
premium content and the chris jenner
video was pretty good it was a little
frustrating like they kept skipping
steps in the makeup routine
because it was steps that kylie
cosmetics like didn't make they didn't
use anything other than kylie cosmetics
which was annoying were you
really there for the steps like barely
and also she started with foundation and
like
i really wanted to see how kris jenner
would have done her fudge what do you
mean oh she was already wearing
foundation
yeah got it yeah that's always like i
want to see
i want to see the goods yeah i hate when
it's like just my makeup and it's
like my eyes they literally come in with
like what i wear on
every day except for lipstick so i just
i really need kylie to invest more in
her youtube channel i know she's a
studio like in her apartment
i mean in her house in her office like
please like for us i haven't watched a
video yet did you watch halloween
cookies with stormy
um i did i haven't watched it one ego
yet you know but like literally it's
funny because there's
halloween cookies with stormy and then
like two videos back chris christmas
vlog so it's literally four vlogs a year
maybe she does it's a q1 q2 q3 and q4
maybe or maybe just what the people want
our cookies with stormy like that's what
tested that's what got the highest q
score yeah maybe storm is just a star
i mean she is a star does she just call
her starmie
oh man show me the star it's starving
okay i'm gonna watch those yeah it's a
fabulous if you have like no if you
need to kill 15 minutes you know yeah
yeah i i always need to kill 50 minutes
but it never occurs to me until i go to
my youtube app
youtube app is so fabulous quite i
watched my favorite podcast the morning
toast on there
oh my god they are so funny those girls
no those girls like
i'm not gonna lie like i i had my my
doubts about them just like hearing what
you know evil people say about them
and then it's like i just gave the time
to like listen to their show and follow
them on instagram and it's so clear that
they're really
smart nice girls who just have such good
intentions
and it's just crazy to me that like
people say all these terrible things
about them when
i've only known them to be like
literally so kind
so lovely so smart and just like want to
make people happy and in turn have
become villains
i honestly i think it's a really
interesting you know sociological
experiment
i agree and is it just me or is that dog
getting cuter and is it just me or is
that brunette like
so [ __ ] snatched and beautiful and is
it just me or her eyelashes looking
so beautiful thank you i got an eyelash
lift honestly like i saw your before and
after pictures
and i had never been interested in an
eyelash lift before but now i have
eyelash envy
well let me just say the actual
experience of the
procedure was so unpleasant like i was
regretting it
so much when i was laying there the
patches that they stick
in your eye and then they glue up your
lashes it's just a it's not painful it's
just very unpleasant and an unnatural
way
to lay down with your like head back and
your eyelashes glued it's just very
dis what's the word when you're you wake
up and you're so like
disorienting yes it's very disorienting
and i was really regretting it and then
when i got up and looked in the mirror
it was like the best money and the best
45 minutes i'd ever spent
i might go somewhere else because i just
feel like i have a couple complaints
about it okay but for the most part like
my lashes
i feel like i'm the perfect candidate
for a lash lift i don't have short
lashes i have very long lashes that go
straight yeah so it's like i curl them
so hard they never stay up this is just
basically taking a curling iron
to my lashes and it's an unbelievable
experience i highly recommend
if you've been thinking about it okay
good to know and they tint them
so they just look even more pronounced i
think the last process of
what you just described is very similar
to my eyelash tinting like you lay there
with your head back and it's not
comfortable and a lot of times like the
dye gets in your eye and like
it's really [ __ ] painful but you're
like beauty is pain and you just sit
there and like you can't open your eyes
so you like kind of have a tear coming
down but you don't want to get like dye
all over your face yes
um so i think i actually might be cut
out for the tint but can i say i've
actually
i got eyelash extensions once and it
wasn't nearly as annoying like either i
didn't go to a good place or it's just
like a
really unpleasant experience because
i've gotten eyelash extensions before
and it's like it's not the best but it's
not a big deal eyelash work can be
unpleasant
it's a very sensitive area it is and
it's just a very small
hair that you're doing a lot too and
it's also very weird to like
be forced to keep your eyes closed do
you know what i mean
well yes but i'm i'm so used to it i've
been dyeing my eyelashes since high
school so it's like
that's what that's what you get for an
eyelash procedure yeah it's just strange
yeah i can imagine but i highly
recommend it it looks really good thank
you
okay our next story exciting news but
i'm skeptical
okay jamie lynn spears teases zoey 101
cast reunion
are you ready i know you see
me standing here
do i look good my dear
do i look good today
yeah if you wanna play
come and play today let's get away
yeah i will make you see
all of the things that you gotta be
believe in yourself and follow the trees
yeah yeah yeah
claudia that's beautiful wait um okay
say the story and then i have thoughts
so jamilyn spears is teasing a zoey 101
cast reunion she posted
a teaser on her instagram saying we're
back are you ready
she also tagged her co-stars sean flynn
who plays chase matthews aaron sanders
who plays quinn pesky
matthew underwood who plays logan reece
and chris massey who plays michael
barrett
she also christmassy um
she also tags it's not in this article
but who is she uh she's an instagram
girl she's to date
or is dating diplo she's like the big
instagram girl
what hold on she's not part of zoe 101
at all
but she got tagged but she got tagged by
jamie lynn spears do you think it was
a like a mistake um no i
chantal jeffries she said she said oh
and hey at
chantal jeffries that is very strange
yeah but that you described her
perfectly the instagram girl who did
maybe dating diplo yeah she's just like
always in vegas
yeah yeah she's the instagram girl yeah
like the one
the one and the only um so i feel like
the cast of zoey 101
of all the shows that people like were
obsessed with as a kid is like
probably the thirstiest like excluding
jamie because she's so
like on another level but like all the
sub characters
they're all over my tic tac her little
brother do you remember him
yeah he is like a disgusting tick tocker
like dustin
jack justin thank you jackie he's on tik
tok
it's like he does like sexual
pornographic tick tocks it's so
concerning because like
yes he might be 21 now but he's always
going to be 12 at like in my house right
of course and he's like literally on
tick-tock with his whip and his like
shirt unbuttoned and it's like making
sec it's so disgusting like you have to
go
guys check out his name is paul
something check out his take out
she didn't tag him but they've all been
together recently like doing tick tocks
on his page except for jamie lynn
because jamieland is like so above the
fridge i just want to say when i'm
speaking about the cast i'm not
referring to jason lynn okay
i'm saying all of them are so [ __ ]
thirsty but jamie lynn did post this and
i just when i went to her instagram i
saw she posted like a nine
image grid so like she's serious about
this and i have i need zoey for the zoey
101 reboot
i don't know i feel like they tried to
live in a post zoe world
and it didn't work but i'm just really
like if they're gonna do a zoe 101
reboot like i needed to be
premium i need to go back to pepperdine
university
pca and i need it to be beautiful
stunning and smart like if
if any of this has anything to do with
zoom
like i will literally i'll boycott
pick it yeah i agree no don't don't
disgrace the franchise just because you
want to get a
reboot out and quarantine like take the
time go to pepperdine university in
malibu and recreate pacific coast
academy
it's worth the effort yeah even if it's
like i don't know how
why zoey would be in boarding school but
whatever it is maybe they're in college
or something you know maybe zoey's kids
are now going to pca
because she they've heard maybe zoe zoe
zoe and chase
ended up together this is my clip my
call they have kids now
and their kids are like i want to go to
pca so
joey the show starts with zoe and chase
taking their kids
up to pca and then running into like all
their old school mates who also are now
chopping their kids off for the first
day at pca
yeah i just don't know if the ages line
up because that would mean that like all
of the pca kids had like
kids at 18. oh i guess but no the kids
could be young um
yeah you're right you're right yeah yeah
yeah in order for them to be interesting
they have to be like at least 10.
maybe well how how old are how old is
jamie lynn i want to say like i'm going
to say 30
because i think she's like around my age
yeah and like five year old she's 29.
five-year-old kids don't go to boarding
school yeah she's 29. [ __ ]
okay i mean we have to think like how
full our house did it like what's gonna
bring
all these kids together at the age of 30
back to pca
maybe the show doesn't involve pca which
would be terrible
right that pca is next to jamie lynn pca
is the biggest character
the the school i completely agree and
like the dorms
and the associates and the key on the
neck like yeah where she if she's not
there like why would she be wearing a
key
yeah like her house key that's a hazard
and the um
like the scooters yeah no it needs to
have the school element so it's so fast
maybe maybe it's like um a 10-year
reunion
special yeah like they all go back to
pca for their tenure reunion i hate a
reunion special
i know like i want to reboot all
firing and all cellulars why i would
want nothing at all
um really quickly no pressure did you
watch snl no uh i watched musical
performances
i watched just like a few sketches on
youtube um i have to say justin bieber's
performance of holy was so unbelievably
like
moving i never thought i would say that
about a justin bieber performance his
vocals were incredible i love chance the
rapper
they both are people who are very
musically talented so it's like
their performance sounded just like
itunes it was really fabulous justin
field felt like he was
very emotional and i was like feeling it
it was excellent
i thought his performance of lonely was
very good and i thought sorry i did a
good job it was a good
um
episode okay i'm glad i'm glad to hear
it i liked his performance of lonely
because i'm just like really feeling
that song except when i was watching it
on snl and he was playing jacob tremblay
um
it just like made me really sad no the
song is perfect like it's
terribly sad it's like a sad song and i
think everyone these days like things
about being lonely and like
depressed and anxious and like that's
like how we're all feeling
um but like it was so personal emotional
and raw
i felt like oh i shouldn't be watching
like this is too personal no but it's
like everyone sings about being lonely
now because i feel like it's
kind of in the zeitgeist to be like open
about
your mental health where it's like when
justin bieber was 12 like literally no
one gave a [ __ ] if he was lonely it's
like go back to work you know
he was really like put through a tough
time and and i actually feel for him
like i really do
yeah no i if he wanted to write a song
like
you know i bet this is how it started he
says oh i want to write a song about
being lonely when he was 11 because
that's how he's feeling and
the person who wrote his song said okay
and he wrote one less lonely girl like
the person was confused
like that it just wasn't an option
justin like had this song in his diary
for years and like
now that he's finally able to do his
whatever his own man he's like
i'm gonna give like my 12 year old self
freedom liberation because i also feel
like now that he's married you know
marriage like you have someone to talk
to and somebody is listening i do feel
like haley is listening
oh i think she listens a lot i think
she's probably an amazing listener
yeah i feel like this song is like
more pre-hailey you know yes of course
no it's literally
one less slowly girl days and then when
he's like living in that big house like
throwing eggs
yeah but that's when he was talking
about like idiot kid yeah that was like
throwing eggs and
we all were watching him throwing eggs
like and we were like
that was such a weird like this is so
horrible and it was really horrible
but like nobody ever thought like maybe
he's lonely maybe it's a cry for help
yeah yeah the egg thing was strange
yeah eggs are really [ __ ] nasty like
especially when you're throwing them at
people and things
no it's so like 90s josie grossi that
it's you we don't throw eggs anymore
it's so wasteful like
yeah no you can make a bomb frittata but
he's a different person now
so i agree and i don't hold people
you know i don't hold a grudge because
he threw eggs five years ago you know
yeah we all do things okay our next
story is some really exciting news about
someone who we love
bachelorette alum emily maynard welcomes
her fifth child a baby girl
i cannot believe she keeps having babies
like it's so crazy
this is what she always wanted literally
when she was a bachelorette and chris
harrison was like where do you see
yourself in whatever five years and
she's like
i see myself in a minivan like truck
full of kids and
like her dreams are coming true and i
love to i really do love to see like
someone getting exactly what they've
manifested right no that's what rupaul
says he's like when you become the when
your life becomes like what you
envisioned it's like the most powerful
thing like you accomplish exactly
what you set out to like have in your
life and it's very powerful
and i love this for her yeah she has
welcomed her fifth child and
fourth with her husband tyler johnson
who she married in 2014 on sunday the
star shared a video from the hospital
which documented the birth of the
couple's baby girl
um we don't have a name yet but she said
welcome to our world
i absolutely like there is a special
place in my heart
little tiny corner carved out for emily
maynard like
she far and away my favorite
bachelorette like just
what a classy girl
and she's one of those people who's been
through like a lot of
tragedy and like you just want her life
to be filled with joy because like you
know
that tragedy where she like just had a
baby and the father of her baby just
died you know like
i i want her to have no it wasn't even
that it was that
she was pregnant sorry yeah but she
didn't find out until after he died
she didn't know she was pregnant until
after her uh fiance died oh my god i
mean it's so tragic like
and i i want so many blessings for her
and if this is how she
you know wants to live her life with a
million children i think that's
wonderful
i think it's wonderful and beautiful and
we're really happy for her and
we'll never pass on a chance to talk
about emily maynard yeah and you also
just don't have that many
like celebrity socialite influencers who
have five babies it's like rare
you know yeah no i mean it's a lot of
babies it's like her and angelina jolie
and james van der beek like that's it
yeah but like him might get there oh
that's true
the karashians have so many kids they do
have so many kids i think they went from
being like mason
to being 30 of them i know i think it's
a good trend
i agree okay our next story is not
something that you saw but i did and it
really got me
got me shook because billy eilish's
optical illusions shoes
sparked a bait and it's the dress all
over again
so bailey eilish posted on her instagram
story um she was like remember the dress
lol
and then she's like it's so funny
because i have these pair of shoes and
my dad thinks they're white and pink and
they're mint and
white or whatever and so she's showing
us them and they're literally white and
pink and i guess she got a million
responses were like
those are white and they're white and
pink like but do do other people think
that it's different
um i don't know i really don't know how
someone could
here what color are those white and pink
white and pink and like they're
she keeps being like no you guys they're
mint and showing more and like
white and pink wait billy thinks that
they're
they're mint and white okay and wait
you'll see this
this is the crazy thing about colors
this is the crazy how do i know
what this is green like how do we know
that green is the same it's so crazy
she's literally like going to google and
showing the shoe that she bought it's
mint like she bought him in shoe it
doesn't come in the white and pink
thing but the way she keeps showing the
shoe white and pink right
wait what but then look at this mint and
white
no that's pink and white for me oh to me
i can see that one is mint and white and
it literally became this whole thing the
more she just
kept going the more she tried to this is
so funny prove that um
they're mint and white the more clear it
was that they're white and pink but like
they really are mint and white but like
will you show me the original shoe
that's mint and white
yes they are the nike up tempo mint and
white hold on
this is so crazy these color things that
like trick your eyes like the contrast
really freaked me out like
it's it's wild here these are the show
oh wow they're literally mint and white
but the way that she keeps okay so now
go back to
her picture for a second okay sorry
if this is uninteresting to you guys
like just the way that the light totally
makes the white makes the mint look
white and the white look pink
oh you know what video comes out today
you know how every year for the last
three years um billy eilish has done a
vanity fair interview yes
it comes out today oh that's exciting i
think these shoes are the best promotion
for that because i hope she'll discuss
i'm so i love stuff like the dress like
when the dress happened that to me is
like my perfect sort of
well cultural moment i love something
that brings us together yeah like but
also like we're divided
because it's like i saw it as white and
gold obviously because i can see
when you saw the dress did you see white
white and gold eventually i was able to
see it as black and blue
like i could see what others were seeing
but like when i see it my eyes go to
white and gold
mine was black and blue and like just
remember like laurel and yanny
of course of course who could forget
laurel and yeah
no i actually think that laurel amiani
is crazier
because um white like i could see when
you adjust the contrast and maybe people
who have like lighter eyes like i'm sure
there is actually like a
scientific explanation for why we see it
the way that we see it but
literally i was like oh he's saying
laurel and then like the next day i
heard yanny and i'm like someone changed
the clip no i know it's and like it's
not like laurel and yanny are such
similar words no they have the all but
still like it's
so bizarre i love things like that like
mnemonic tricks
and she really it was the crazy watching
her try and prove and she was like
literally suck my dick like these are
mint and white that's so funny um
billy eilish was also photographed uh
like taking out the trash and a tank top
which was like very rare for her and i
saw the most disgusting article like
ever being circulated it was like
six times billy eilish ditched her baggy
clothes like get the
like that's so disgusting like she's a
child like yeah it was really gross i
saw all the commentary around the photo
but i just
didn't want to participate in it because
she's a beautiful young woman
and then it's like doing her chores
that's why that's why she wears baggy
clothes she's helping out around the
house even though she's like the number
one grammy winner of all time right now
it's like i don't even take out the
trash like i think that i'm so special
i'm like ben get rid of it
and like billy eilish takes out the
trash we could all learn a thing too
from her if billy eilish can take out
the trash so can you
yeah i'm sorry i know it's not what you
wanted to hear this morning but
it's true okay our fifth and final story
is little happy couple news because zac
efron is celebrating his 33rd birthday
with girlfriend
vanessa valadares and he had a
girlfriend
yeah he's dating a vanessa and she's not
the vanessa but she's a vanessa that
makes him happy
and so for that reason i am pleased as
well he is so like off the grid
he is obviously going to australia he
started the show about being off the
ground yeah and like almost
died whilst leaving the grid yeah
yeah he's um it's not what i saw for him
you know
yeah at one point in the height of his
movie career with like neighbors
greatest showman like
i was like he's gonna be like one of the
biggest movie stars in the world and he
just kind of no he still is
no but like he doesn't want the like
celebrity like the typical celebrity
aspect
of that but as far as like his career
trajectory like
going from being like um who
what was his name philip carlisle to
ted bundy like he's on track to link
larkin
he's he's everything of the story yeah
this actually might be maybe one of my
most controversial statements but i
think that
everything zac efron has ever done pales
in comparison to his work in hairspray i
think it's
the role of a lifetime no i think that
his
role in hairspray like it was the
perfect role for him because it was
everything that he was so used to doing
which is high school musical
and then like so like so
hollywood hollywood serious he nailed it
he [ __ ] nailed it yeah i mean we
talked about this like i think once
every six months about how the most
recent
you know revival of hairspray starring
nikki blonsky and zac efron
is quite possibly the most well-cast
movie
on the planet yes and the but the most
recent revival was hairspray live
sorry film revival yeah it's just so
sensational between amanda mines as
peggy
and zac efron as link larkin and queen
latifah as
motor mouth maybelle there's just so
many
excellent oh jerry steeler as
mr pinky and john travolta and
christopher walken as the parents it's
just like
there's not one person i would have
changed in terms of casting i agree i
even feel that way about hairspray live
i think the casting was on point i think
like hairspray just always has great
casting yeah but unfortunately
um there was hairspray live just it
didn't cut it
it didn't cut it i wonder when they're
going to do another one of those lives
we're really banging them out for a
while can i be honest i think never they
had wrench
grease hairspray yep sound of music
peter pan um the whiz
the wiz and i think that like those
lives were like the pinnacle of like
everything pre-covered yeah you know and
a little unnecessary
no it's like we can do this so we will
but like literally nobody else would
also just like spend all this time
recording and making it perfect as
opposed to like making sure
someone doesn't break his ankle the day
before no it was like so unnecessarily
extra you're right
and so for that i don't think it's gonna
come back i'm okay
i think the lives were a moment in time
yeah and you know i was glad to have
experienced it yeah even though
greece live was utter perfection
julianne huff should be so proud of
herself so should vanessa and hudgens
her dad died the night before and she
still did it
yeah so those lives were really made for
vanessa hudgens and no one else no
there's a few people who would like it
was really right
vanessa hodgins kiki palmer and in a lot
of ways like ariana grande like getting
to act and also like
yeah was perfect for her as well yeah
she played penny pingleton
that was good that was good i don't know
i was so excited for hairspray live and
then like zach forgot to record it so we
missed the first half and like i was and
by the second half they were all out of
breath
and like it was so bad that they
actually never put on a streaming
service like i never got to watch it i
literally had hairspray live like
written in my planner i was
so excited it was like early days of
sack and i dating and like he didn't
record and i was like oh my god this
isn't gonna work out red flag
yeah yeah that's horrible when somebody
doesn't record something for you it's
like
you you're so angry like there's you
can't go back like there's nothing you
could do about it no no especially when
it's like a one night only yeah
one night special yeah one night only
one dream girls live or just a dream
girls movie that's
filmed properly and i could use another
one yeah so good
but anyways the couple was joined by a
star-studded group of friends that's the
toasty snack
wait what are we talking about vanessa
oh
sorry and zac efron is 33.
we get to say it again zach and vanessa
second friend's 33.
troy bolton how old was he when you
think he played troy balton he was at
high school
uh sophomore and junior so like 15
15 16. he's been famous for half his
life that's a lot of time
yeah i mean he's been through a lot yeah
he almost died on his off the grid thing
no but also like personally
you know yeah i mean i feel like ever
since him and vanessa broke up he just
hasn't been able to find a love like
that
i know you guys go watch high school
musical you'll never be the same it's
true
jackie was being dramatic high school
musical as a 30 year old you'll never be
the same
no it's really good it's so good the
third one is arguably the best
you can make the argument about any of
them really because two
there's a lot of controversy surrounding
too there's a lot of like political
like sniffs
in that movie no here's why i think
three is the best because two is not the
best while it was like an interesting
take they weren't in the school and like
you got to be in high school for high
school school
and i liked the country club stuff but
it wasn't it's a good
it was awesome but it's not an excellent
sequel yeah but i think the third is
better than the first because the third
had everything the first really needed
it was the third was released in
theaters so it was like really big
hollywood buddy
they were a little older so they kissed
where it's like the first movie they
didn't even kiss
yeah well i mean they were sophomores
like inappropriate
no i was doing way worse when i was a
sophomore
i'm kidding
um okay before are we done with the
story um
yeah i mean they were with a
star-studded group of friends at a party
in byron bay as seen in photos in the
daily mail um which also reported that
guests included chris and liam
hemsworth's
dad oh greg um that's weird
a tennis pro a radio host oh kyle
sanderlands who i think he hosts with
kyle and jackie oh
oh my god you're our chemist so my
no we support we're jackie o's who's
supportive like sometimes like if she's
going through something like you'll get
like the end of her press and i'm sure
she yeah
she is mine yeah honestly we have her an
apology and every once in a while i'll
get like
people commenting you're not the real
jackio
yeah i wonder if she's heard of me
probably probably not
i'm an adventurer and say yeah the girl
who's disgracing her name like
taking a dump on her google seo search i
think that it's
definitely possible that she knows who
you are i'm sorry wait so chris and liam
hemsworth
step dad craig was at the party yeah but
chris and liam were nowhere to be found
no yeah no they didn't say interesting
real houses of potomac was
so boring last night and you know what
she said i'm
i feel like now enough episodes have
passed where i can make a royal decree
about this season like
not only do i feel like it's such a
boring season but i feel like it's not
for lack of
substance like there were there was a
major event that just happened and i
still feel like even the episode with
the major event was a little boring like
i just feel like something about the
editing and some of the other women like
is
so boring and i i hate that it has come
to this i really do
yeah i totally agree i made my decision
like a week ago and two weeks ago but
then last week firmed up that i'm fully
team monique and then this week like
solidified and it's so nice when you
make your decision and then like
everything else that you wish just
proves to you that you made the right
decision and you're not like constantly
trying to
figure it out um i think the this
episode went to show that like monique
is integral
to the entertainment factor 100 of the
show
um and every like it just
proves what we've been saying like i
think gisele and robin were like so
excited for a reason
to take down monique and now and they've
all like kind of
you know encouraged candace to take this
legal route and like
now candace is saying she wants monique
and jill and they're like wait
right so let's talk about the crux was
that she actually filed second degree
assault charges towards monique last
night
monique on her twitter because monique
wasn't even in the episode posted an
email of the letter
posted a screenshot of the email she got
from candace's attorneys
and was really trying to insinuate that
monique was um
felt like candace was using this
experience to get money from monique
and the email was like if you do not
respond we'll file a class action
lawsuit which means like getting money
um and monique really felt like this is
candace was not really looking for
justice or trying to get monique to go
to jail like in the end she wanted to
get paid out by monique which
honestly i never thought of but kind of
makes sense
yeah i that is so crazy to me like
when the fight first went down we're
like oh my gosh okay this is crazy like
everyone
let's take a step back reevaluate and
now it's like you're really going to
court like over some
hair pulling no and and her like waking
up every morning like
with trauma i'm i can't no and what
monique said i think maybe she said it
on twitter it's like
it of course monique feels it was not
second-degree assault because they were
both fighting with each other and maybe
if you slow it down you could argue that
yes monique started at first but they
were hitting each other
candace threw a glass so like
technically they both have grounds to
stand
on legally right and also if this did go
to court i'm sure they had the footage
and they replayed it and maybe they
didn't um have
the tick tock that i saw which is that
candace
put her hands on monique first right um
and that's
that's really what's so crazy about the
whole thing is the women are talking as
if like
monique was so clearly in the wrong but
like when you
she was flipping her hair which isn't
like a the right thing to do but
candace was being annoying but candace
touched monique's
body first and that's what ashley was
saying she was like
you like ashley's an amazing friend i
love her the fact that candice can't
even on the smallest level acknowledge
her part in this like as if literally
this just
happened to her and fell in her lap and
she was like you were like antagonizing
her and you were provoking her like
can you just at least own that like
let's say we all agree monique is wrong
but like
you're not gonna own any part any of
your part in this like
to act like this whole thing just
happened to her i just i find her
insufferable i really do and i just feel
like this
whole saga is part of the reason why
she's the like the worst housewife
because to be honest
in the beginning it was so clearly like
she was the victim and now i just
i can't stand her again i can't stand
her and like for her to
for her when they got into their fight
like candace was you know she was
dragging me money driving what are you
going to drag me
and then so she they get it and then she
gets
dragged and then her now her approach is
like crying ptsd victim victim and it's
like
either like talk the talk and yeah
but like to go from being like you're
right so strong
drag me monique and then she gets your
hair pulled and now she's like in court
yeah crying with but if you want to be
strong before be strong after
yeah no that's a very good point she's
very inconsistent yeah
i just i really can't stand her and you
know what like
i don't like the way chris spoke to her
and when he was like shut up shut up but
like i know what he was saying he's like
literally you're in the right like
you're digging your grave when you
were one you were digging moniques right
and when she said the comment to ashley
about like not for long it's like
oh that's what it is she's so nervous
right now we're all reminded as to why
you got your hair
pulled in the first place no no when she
said that and like ashley really was not
coming from
ashley was being like she wasn't being
nasty she wasn't she was just having
genuine conversation and not everyone is
ever going to agree on stuff but
but when you talk about it like civil
human beings it's like a it's a lovely
way to
to have a conversation and she didn't
come out
you know angry or anything and candace
just like
like totally dismissed her yeah when she
had a valid concern and she raised it in
a very normal calm way
and ashley was like the only one who was
just gonna mention the other side of
things where it's like it's a table
of everyone just like affirming what the
other things and like
ultimately that's not productive because
there's two
people in this situation two sides that
need to reconcile
i also have a lot of respect for karen i
think she's in a much more difficult
place than anyone else because ashley
like i think you know is happy to have a
chance
to get back at candace for all of the
things that she's done and
you know ashley like knows candace so
she's less inclined to like believe her
victim
hood yes and ashley and monique have a
good friendship and monique had ashley's
back last season because we don't know
if she had that footage in her house
right
of michael but like right i it felt like
she had ashley's back so this is an easy
choice for ashley to have monique's back
for karen i i think her two closest
friends in the group are monique and
candace
and she is in the middle and the fact
that like some of the women won't let
her be in the middle they're forcing her
to take a side like i think that that
that they are wrong in that situation
and being in the middle like karen said
it's the absolute worst place to be
but the fact that candace thinks that
because karen's in the middle she's
prioritizing monique's feelings is
exactly why candace can't see
like the truth also really quickly about
footage did you see that video that went
viral this week a reddit user who was
watching old episodes
of potomac realized
um in the very background of like a
major scene i guess no one was paying
attention at the time to what was going
on in the background
but michael is caught fondling i think
it was a producer or like
a passer buyer no it looked like someone
who was working on the show because i
think he was wearing a headset
right um which just goes to prove pretty
much
everything that um has been going on the
last few seasons it was just a crazy
if you're interested like just search on
twitter or on reddit for the video it's
wild yeah it's really wild the only
other thing i wanted to talk about from
the episode was
um can't uh no wendy's
party i found all the like nigerian
culture stuff to be so interesting i
love people who go on tv and like are so
proud of their culture and just like
want to teach the world about like
ebo and what and like the head dresses i
just loved it and i thought it was
fabulous and it was actually a wonderful
party like
um very well put together i think
whoever did the uh decor did a good job
the food looked delicious too my food
looked delicious um i agree i love
learning about
other people's cultures on television
and i thought it was really beautiful to
see she's such a i mean the stuff with
her in-laws
is crazy exciting but like core family
she's such a beautiful family
oh agreed and it seems as though she has
a really wonderful marriage
yeah it's it's lovely to watch what's so
crazy about her in-law situation it's
like it's not like you know
can't it's not like wendy is some you
know like vagrant
like she's literally so accomplished she
has four degrees she's an amazing mother
she's a political analyst she's a
professor
and her husband's family like doesn't
like her like what's that's
like yeah she's incredibly accomplished
she's the type of woman you hope your
son marries
right she's not like you know i think
that's what makes
it so weird extra sad for them too
yeah you know yeah i actually really um
like enjoy watching her home scenes
because i think her she's a really good
husband
and her kids are like very cute and very
well behaved and just like seeing her
husband like get the kids dressed was
just like wow that's nice like you don't
really see that in housewives
yeah i thought it was cute and all the
kids wearing pink were super cute and
also robin dixon getting to the party
early before
wendy was so funny um and robin dixon
in the rotate dress that
yes jane and lisa rena also wore but as
andy pointed out and watch what happens
live
i believe that robin scene was filmed
before that beverly hills scene
so robin is the trendsetter here and i
just want to say i think that for every
event
the women of potomac should be given a
color um because
they look wonderful it works they
actually all looked amazing and then
they also looked amazing together and
i think that some sort of structure like
that even also at the
wine tasting before it went south like
everyone had like a wine tasting vibe
and looked really good but
it was like browns but like the dinner
at the lake house
just not it but it was also a confusing
lake house i honestly i give them yeah
no
a pass for that yeah um the fine the
other thing i wanted to
say oh robin dixon's hat company
yeah yeah i just think we should leave
it at that
you know yeah she like in so many ways
she makes me sad you know
well um they look comfortable and then
she made 10 grand
and i hope that she does well like i i
really do
yeah i just feel like i want to get in
there and like help her with her
finances you know what i mean not that i
know anything about finances but she's
on tv
like she's like yeah how no here's the
thing how come we didn't know she had a
hat company before
right how come she like is making
literally making her own hats and i'm
not
they do look really comfortable and i
could see them being like really popular
and she's never once promoted them i've
never heard of embellished before on the
show right but i've heard of live dom
30 000 times that's how you brand yours
and i would
bet you ladam is selling way more units
than the hats are because i literally
never even heard about that like
and andy on march travis live was like
can you send me a hat she was like you
want one like you should be sending
everyone hats like
this yes actually could be something
because first of all housewives
businesses are very successful and like
hats are a great thing no housewife is
in the hat industry
and that hats look like really nice hats
and it's hard to find a nice hat i agree
and if she was wearing the hats in every
episode every time they went somewhere
every time
someone had a party you know you get the
hat embroidered
like she's doing so she could be doing
so much and it's wasting the opportunity
like i think kyle richards might have
sold more agency hats
yeah a hundred percent than robin and
her hat company and it's a waste of an
opportunity
and and i like the name embellished no
it's like all there but just to hear
about it for the first time it's like in
season
five robin has a hat company no it
seemed so weird like and
off just she she could be doing so much
more
yeah so that that's my critique um
other than that like i said it was a
boring episode but um
i feel like we made it fun we did make
it fun we need monique back i love her
so much
me too and this has just gotten like so
off track
yeah we have the bachelorette tonight
right monday
yes it's a bachelorette wow
i can't believe it's literally already
been a week since the last one yeah
our recap segment after dale will be
live tomorrow when we recap what might
happen
after dale and the official tnn bachelor
after show
slash recap show is the snatcher it
just subscribe to it anywhere you get
your podcast like itunes or spotify um
she's doing episodes every week there's
one last week if you want to catch up
and she's the t she really does like she
knows everything she knows everything
and then also like when you listen you
get to like
know more about the snitch and that's so
complicated that's why i listen
really it's just like full of snitch tea
yeah it's
heavy it's stitched um and that's our
show
and then also theo's podcast is dropping
soon so stay tuned for that here's a
little sneak peek
no in that first episode we got a
preview when he was like
i was like no and then he said and i'm
like yeah
it's it's really great it'll have you
and your feelings so just make sure
you're following him on instagram pops
with no job that is our show
and if i may close it out i think you
can thank you guys so much for listening
to the morning toast similarly morning
show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
morning monday through friday on youtube
so if you're watching us on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we are also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so that's spotify itunes
stitch or public radio i have read a cat
box all the places wherever you listen
to podcasts
find us the morning toast and leave a 5
star review about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are
we hope you have an amazing day we'll
see you tomorrow for tuesday's episode
goodbye goodbye